bonjour bonjour Christian prud'hommes
merci beaucoup d'être notre invité ce
matin vous êtes le directeur du Tour de
France je vous en prie installez-vous
Tour de France qui s'est lancera ce
samedi 1er juillet ce sera la 110e
édition du Tour de France dont on dit
qu'elle est la course la plus dure au
monde en quoi est-elle si particulière
c'est la plus grande course cycliste du
monde c'est l'une des plus anciennes
c'est le plus ancien des grands tours on
les grands tours donc d'Italie d'Espagne
et de France c'est une épreuve qui est
bien plus que du sport encore assez
c'est de la culture c'est de l'histoire
c'est la géographie c'est la mise en
valeur de nos régions nos départements
de patrimoine grâce à la prise de vue
aérienne qui la prise de vue dominante
le Tour de France est retransmis du
premier au dernier kilomètre 4 5 6
heures 7 heures par jour suivant la
durée de l'étape la distance de l'étape
et les images partent dans 190 pays dans
le monde c'est dire que c'est la
meilleure bande annonce possible au-delà
du sport pour le premier pays
touristique au monde qui est notre pays
la France
comment vous qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de du Tour de France de cette
année qu'est-ce que vous avez cherché à
faire avec le parcours que vous avez
décidé
au delà du parcours c'est d'abord la
revanche c'est le match retour entre le
Danois Wingard qui a remporté les
problèmes l'année dernière et le prodige
sloven pocketcha donc match retour
revanche nous ne sommes pas de vins on
verra ce que ça a donné en revanche le
départ de Bilbao d'Espagne du Pays
Basque nous au pied des Pyrénées nous
permettait d'inscrire les cinq massifs
montagneux français c'est-à-dire les
Pyrénées le Massif central le Jura les
Alpes puis les Vosges pour une sorte de
diagonale qui va nous mener jusqu'en
Alsace avant le retour à Paris puisqu'en
2023 nous arriverons bien à Paris ce qui
sera différent on va en parler
évidemment comment vous élaborez le
parcours du Tour de France quels sont
vos critères alors nous nous avons il
faut d'abord que les villes où les
départements ou les régions soient
candidats ou candidates nous avons 300
candidatures pour une trentaine de
places 250 candidatures françaises une
cinquantaine à l'étranger il y a ensuite
les règles de l'Union cycliste trois
semaines de course 21 étapes de journée
de repos 3500 km au maximum le tour
était beaucoup plus long autrefois quand
j'étais gamin il faisait 4000 4500 dans
les années 20 il a même fait jusqu'à
5700 km et il y a presque le double de
ce qui était de ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui et ensuite il y a évidemment
un équilibre entre les étapes de plaine
les étapes de montagne et les cours sont
en ligne des étapes contre la montre etc
il y a des éléments incontournables
alors oui c'est-à-dire que non seulement
j'assume mais je revendique les grands
départs à l'étranger qui n'ont rien de
récent puisque le premier était en 1954
et la première arrivée du Tour de France
à l'étranger oui la première arrivée
d'étape du Tour de France à l'étranger
c'était 1919 avec Genève sans tenir
compte de Metz à leur allemande en 1907
mais ce qui est très important pour moi
quand je vous dis ça c'est que il est
possible d'avoir et il faut avoir des
grandes villes françaises étrangères
parce qu'il y a la rince parce qu'il y a
Châtillon-sur-Chalaronne parce qu'il y a
Poligny la capitale du comté ou Moirans
en Montagne la capitale du joueur en
bois c'est à dire que le Tour de France
doit parler à tout le monde il doit
faire rayonner davantage quand nous
sommes partis du Yorkshire en 2014 avec
un succès populaire phénoménal j'ai
appris qu'à l'époque 11 millions de
Britanniques passaient par dessus la
France pour aller en vacances en Espagne
si une fraction de ces gens-là attiré
par le Tour de France regarde notre pays
la France on a peut-être pas tout perdu
au-delà de la compétition qui est
néanmoins la plus grande course au monde
et du coup parce qu'il y a eu Copenhague
l'année dernière il y a Bilbao cette
année il y aura Florence l'année
prochaine vous souhaitez systématiser
ces départs à l'étranger pourquoi les
systématiser les faire régulièrement oui
mais les trois départs consécutifs à
l'étranger n'étaient pas prévu c'est la
pandémie qui a fait qu'il a fallu
inverser la Bretagne et merci infiniment
à la région Bretagne d'avoir accepté
d'accueillir le tour un an plus tôt et
Copenhague ne pouvait plus à cause de la
pandémie et de ses conséquences c'est à
dire que le championnat d'Europe de foot
avait changé une année les Jeux
Olympiques et que nos amis de la loi se
retrouvaient avec le foot et le tour au
même moment ce qui était impossible en
terme de sécurité
mais mais en revanche
c'est une évidence et c'est nécessaire
mais en revanche regardez le succès
populaire de l'an passé au Danemark
c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire que
c'est dans mon esprit c'est même encore
plus l'intérêt de notre pays que
l'intérêt du Tour de partir de
l'étranger c'est faire rayonner
davantage c'est aller chercher des gens
qui aiment le tour et donc la France qui
voient la France avec un regard d'enfant
émerveillé les Danne moi je pense qu'ils
aiment bien la France en ce moment parce
que vous entendez on imagine ces
interrogations les types de certaines
personnes qui disent mais pourquoi le
Tour de France commence à l'étranger
est-ce que ça reste encore le Tour de
France pour vous
c'est la plus grande course cycliste du
monde ça fait que des gens s'intéressent
à nous c'est au contraire c'est c'est
quand on est j'évoquais le Yorkshire
tout à l'heure mais quand en 2014 tous
les noms de pubs dans leads sont
traduits en français quand le black Swan
s'appelle le signe noir les gens qui
critiquent j'ose espérer qu'ils
n'utilisent pas le franglais à tort et à
travers au quotidien défendre le tour
c'est aussi défendre la langue 13 c'est
un savoir-faire Amaury Sport
Organisation quand on va organiser le
Tour de France qu'on va à l'étranger on
montre un savoir-faire français on
montre une excellence française qui est
recherché et vous dites dans un on va
voir un extrait d'un documentaire
Netflix qui passe en ce moment qui
s'appelle Tour de France au cœur du
peloton vous dites dans ce documentaire
le tour est un monument national à
vocation universelle c'est aussi ça que
vous voulez monter exactement
sur les villes étapes parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a un petit peu envie de
comprendre comment vous élaborez le
parcours et comment ça se passe vous le
dites il y a plus de 300 villes qui sont
candidates il y en a 30 qui sont retenus
comment vous les retenez ces villes
quand on décide d'un lieu de départ en
l'occurrence Bilbao on sait qu'on n'ira
pas à Lille on sait qu'on ira pas à
Brest donc si vous voulez un parcours se
dessine on ne sait pas forcément où nous
irons mais en tout cas on sait on ira
pas en revanche si on superpose les
cartes du Tour de France sur 5 ou 6
années on voit qu'on va à peu près
partout la géographie de la France était
essentielle pour tracer le parcours vous
tracez une droite du Pays Basque à
l'Alsace à l'ouest de cette droite il y
a pas de montagne le le parcours si le
parcours était uniquement sportif on
ferait quasiment ce que nous faisons
cette année vous êtes dans la partie à
l'est de cette fameuse droite vous
décidez de faire une table de plaine
vous faites une étape de pleine vous
voulez faire une étape de moyenne
montagne vous faites une étape de
moyenne montagne vous le fait un état de
haute montagne vous faites une étape de
l'autre côté ça n'est pas possible mais
il faut évidemment qu'on aille en
Bretagne notre fameux champion Bernard
Hinault me taillerait les l'homme de
cadorguin et des Côtes-d'Armor mais
tailleraient les oreilles en pointe si
nous allions pu en Bretagne on y va
évidemment régulièrement le succès
populaire était magnifique lorsque nous
sommes partis il y a deux ans mais mais
d'un point de vue sportif les
difficultés qui font les champions du
Tour ben c'est à l'est de cette droite
donc il faut jouer avec tout ça mais
bien sûr qu'on va en Bretagne bien sûr
qu'on va en Vendée bien sûr qu'on va
dans le Nord
par exemple alors l'Alpe d'Huez ça n'est
pas tous les ans mais c'est souvent bien
évidemment mais c'est aussi une ville
comme peau il y a la volonté politique
de d'André labarrer à François Bayrou il
y a toujours eu la volonté politique
pour à l'hébergement peau et sur
l'autoroute ça veut dire que une fois
que l'étape est terminée il faut que les
coureurs aillent vers les hôtels s'il y
a une autoroute c'est quand même plus
facile donc il y a une sorte d'évidence
il y a l'envie la volonté politique il y
a l'accueil mais il y a aussi un lieu
stratégique au pied des Pyrénées en
entrant ou en sortant ça veut dire pour
avoir un équilibre géographique vous y
réfléchissez sur plusieurs années bien
sûr c'est pour ça que je fais ce geste
superposer les cartes du Tour et vous
verrez regardez le départ de de Nice en
2020 le départ de Brest en 2021 puis
depuis le Danemark puis Bilbao
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on va à un coin
que vous fassiez une coupe du monde ou
des Jeux Olympiques alors les Jeux
Olympiques arrivent à Paris en France et
c'est formidable mais c'est peu ouprou
la même chose les Jeux Olympiques tous
les quatre ans le Tour de France en
fonction du lieu du départ il va être
complètement différent si vous partez de
Nice au pied des Alpes de Bilbao au pied
des Pyrénées ou du Danemark tout en haut
ou de Brest ben vous allez être soit
tout de suite dans la montagne soit vous
aurez une semaine dans la plaine et donc
la construction du tour et le résultat
du tour peuvent différer
les villes est-ce qu'elle ça leur coûte
d'accueillir le Tour de France on
imagine que ça leur apporte aussi est-ce
que vous avez des chiffres alors en
général dans les études qui sont faites
par les collectivités c'est de l'ordre
de 1 euro donné pour pour 3 euros qui
rentrent voir 5 6 7 en fonction des
endroits si vous êtes dans des villes
qui ont les hôtels bien évidemment que
le retour il est il est plus fort le
ticket d'entrée du Tour de France or
grand départ qui est différent c'est en
fait ce que nous payons le soir en
hébergement c'est aux alentours de 250
000 euros 130 000 euros une arrivée en
retasse 90 000 un départ alors si on
additionne tout ça 250000 euros c'est à
peu près ce que nous payons tous les
soirs en hébergement pour les coureurs
du Tour les équipes et l'organisation
puisque nous réservons chaque soir 1850
lits donc l'argent demandé aux
collectivités est immédiatement
réinvesti dans l'économie locale dans le
tissu économique local vous rencontrer
des élus tout au long de l'année vous
pour élaborer cette carte que vous
dit-il et que leur dites-vous on imagine
on imagine que c'est un échange qui
laisse passionnant
ils disent un peu désormais qu'ils
veulent le tour aussi dans sa version
féminine ce qui est très bien puisque
nous avons relancé l'année dernière la
version féminine du tour il y a un an et
demi lorsque nous nous avons avec Marion
rousse la directeur de la directrice du
Tour de France lorsque nous avons
annoncé le retour d'une épreuve féminine
j'ai dit vive le tour vive les tours je
m'étais trompé parce que c'est le tour
la version féminine est partie
intégrante du tour au bord des routes
c'est le même public avec peut-être
davantage de femmes et jeunes filles qui
se disent demain je serai peut-être moi
dans le Pluton et je pourrais assouvir
mes rêves avec de très belles audiences
à la télé donc c'est vraiment le tour
c'est un mois de juillet complet
d'évoluer autour de France d'évoluer au
cyclisme avec aussi ce que nous
souhaitons de plus en plus mettre en
valeur le lien entre la bicyclette du
quotidien et le vélo des Champions et
des championnes c'est pour ça que nous
avons créé le label des villes étables
du Tour de France sur le modèle des
villes fleuries pour encourager à la
pratique de la bicyclette au quotidien
notamment auprès des jeunes et pour
faire en sorte que les les villes les
collectivités développent plus encore
leur politique de mobilité douce et ça
c'est important évidemment le Tour de
France et la victime du cyclisme chaque
année c'est l'événement le plus suivi
mais vous voulez vous en servir vous
pour développer ce vélo au quotidien et
que les Français soient plus associés
pourquoi mais c'est très simple parce
que c'est aussi notre intérêt là je dors
du cyclisme français vous ne m'avez pas
encore demandé ah quand un vainqueur du
Tour de France
1985 mais mais là je dors du cyclisme
français c'est quand les les champions
sortaient des fermes les années 50 60 70
pourquoi il prenait leur bicyclette pour
aller à l'école ils faisaient 5 ou 10 km
le matin le midi le soir et il faisait
est-ce qu'ils appellent le Grand Prix de
la pancarte c'est-à-dire qu'il faisait
un sprint devant l'entrée de la commune
du village et donc naturellement ils
étaient repérés donc c'est notre intérêt
aussi bien évidemment
comme comme tout le monde le tour a été
créé par un journal loto il s'est il a
toujours évolué avec les moyens de
communication de son époque la presse
écrite qu'il a créé la radio qu'il a
qu'il a popularisé formidablement la
télé qu'il manifie les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui donc ça va continuer c'est
une invention de journaliste le Tour de
France donc il faut savoir s'adapter
les coulisses de ce Tour de France il y
a une série documentaire qui passe en ce
moment même sur Netflix Tour de France
au cœur du peloton plongé dans les
coulisses de l'année dernière vous
l'avez regardé j'imagine si ça vous a
rappelé de vous souvenir ça m'a surtout
plu effectivement très très bien faite
cette série le cyclisme on va le voir
c'est un sport individuel évidemment
mais on voit que c'est un sport d'équipe
et les coureurs s'accordent à dire et on
s'en rend compte en regardant cette
série on va voir notamment l'importance
des directeurs sportifs on va regarder
un extrait avec Marc Madiot le célèbre
directeur sportif de la Groupama FDJ
regarde
je suis arrivé dans la dernière partie
de ma carrière je voulais créer une
équipe en partant d'une feuille blanche
marqueur vouliez directeur sportif alors
aujourd'hui ça y est on y est zéro
expérience je sortais du peloton et tout
mais j'avais envie et ben ça c'est
l'essentiel
[Musique]
les gens ont envie qu'il soit derrière
le bureau qui soit sur le vélo qui soit
en bas à l'atelier il faut qu'ils aient
envie
puis quand je monte dans ma voiture en
course avec un directeur sportif
if et je veux que les mecs ils rentrent
dans le match
c'est ça le plus important
[Musique]
voilà on voit la ferveur la passion de
mcmaggio un mot peut-être sur Marc radio
il est quand même beaucoup plus connu
que certains coureurs ça devient ça
c'est un ancien vainqueur de
Paris-Roubaix c'était un c'était un vrai
champion j'ai quand j'ai découvert mon
premier tour de France à la radio à
l'époque pour Europe 1 le consultant
s'appelait Marc maillot c'est-à-dire 30
ans et effectivement cette envie qu'il
transmet elle est forte c'est la passion
mais quand on est dans tous les domaines
mais dans le domaine du sport et du
sport de compétition s'il y a pas de
patient c'est quand même pas tout à fait
pareil on ne peut pas aller au bout et
on voit cette passion et on voit surtout
que le cyclisme en fait c'est un sport
d'équipe le plus grand champion la plus
grande championne ne peuvent pas gagner
sans équipe c'est un sport individuel
qui se court par équipe et en effet dans
la série on le voit parfaitement c'est
très quand ce qui me plaît beaucoup
c'est que c'est totalement
complémentaire du direct de France
Télévisions qui est magnifique parce
qu'on voit tout du premier au dernier
kilomètre mais là on découvre les
stratégies on voit que le tableau noir
fonctionne parfois mais pas toujours
comme dans la vie et puis on découvre
des personnages le sprinter Jasper
Philippe scène je le connais de vue je
ne connais pas plus que ça euh dans une
dans un des épisodes de la série on voit
que il ne se rend pas compte qu'un
coureur était arrivé avant il gagne le
sprint et il est tout content et il
arrive il comprend qu'il n'a pas
triomphé il est avec son ami sa compagne
sa femme et elle lui dit mais qu'est-ce
que je fais suis-moi et il dit c'est la
honte c'est la honte je n'ai pas gagné
une seule épreuve sur le Tour pas une
seule étape et là je crois que j'ai
gagné c'est la honte et on découvre
ensuite que ce gars est le roi des gaffe
ce que je ne savais pas il est surnommé
Jasper disaster Jasper le désastre et en
fait partout il oublie ses lunettes si
oui même pas son maillot pour partir
rouler donc c'est j'ai très envie du
coup en arrivant à Bilbao d'aller lui
serrer la main d'aller lui dire ben
voilà j'espère salut on se connaît pas
plus que ça mais donc on peut s'attacher
aux gens du coup on peut s'attacher aux
gens davantage on voit effectivement
dans ce dans cette série documentaire le
rôle des équipes des stratégies aussi
d'équipe et ça pose peut-être la
question de
que les coureurs ont puisque maintenant
ils disposent d'une oreillette pour être
en lien avec leur directeur sportif
est-ce que ça a pas enlevé un peu de
magie à la course de suspense c'était
une question qui avait du sens il y a
trois ou quatre ans qui en a moins
aujourd'hui puisque les cours sont
totalement débridées depuis 3 ou 4 ans
avec une nouvelle génération peut-être
aussi un effet poscovide qui fait que
les champions cyclistes se sont dit nous
on peut encore courir dans le monde est
à l'arrêt parce que ça a été le cas à un
moment ils ont repris plus vite que les
autres l'oreillette moi je suis pas fan
mais il y a bien longtemps en 2008 on a
voulu on a eu l'autorisation puisque ça
ne dépend pas de nous ça dépend pas de
l'organisation du Tour de France ça
dépend des règles international donc de
l'Union cycliste internationale et en
2008 il y a 15 ans nous avions obtenu
l'autorisation de faire deux étapes sans
oreillette et là on a vu six cours
s'échapper un coureur de chacune des six
formations dans le manager était contre
les oreillettes et on a vu se mettre en
tête de peloton 16 coureurs un coureur
pour chacune des 16 formations dans le
directeur sportif était pour les
oreillettes de telle manière à faire
l'étape la plus lancinante possible on
l'a fait donc une fois cette expérience
on l'a pas renouvelé parce que
clairement le monde des équipes était
contre nous dans son ensemble et je
pense pas que ça évolué parce que la
jeune génération de coureurs est
habituée à l'oreillette on va revenir
sur le rôle des directeurs sportifs
parce que le Tour de France il y a
certes beaucoup de villes qui veulent en
être et vous en choisissez mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de coureurs qui va l'en
être et un directeur sportif doit faire
des choix on se souvient que l'année
dernière Julian à la Philippe avait été
écarté parce que il était pas très en
forme suite à sa chute dans le lien
Bastian Liège pardon et cette année
c'est Thibault Pinot qui a été
sélectionné aux dépenses d'Arnaud
démarre Thibault Pinault ce sera son
dernier tour de France c'est un peu une
course maudite pour lui le Tour de
France
le Tour de France je pense que c'est une
épreuve qui l'adore d'ailleurs les
messages que nous avons pu nous échanger
lui et moi depuis trois mois indiquait
très clairement parce que ils faisaient
ça en fait il y avait ça dans tous ces
messages le petit signe en me disant
j'espère que j'en serai j'espère que
j'en serai évidemment que nous aussi on
souhaitait qu'il soit là pourquoi parce
que c'est un personnage du Tour parce
que c'est un grimpeur qui
que ça va déménager ça veut dire que
vous êtes c'est là que je pose ma
question vous êtes optimiste sur un
Français tu peux gagner ton enfance ou
cette année ça va être compliqué deux
trois français dans les 10 premiers
peut-être un dans les cinq premiers
peut-être sur les podium mais personne
ne pourra lutter je pense contre contre
pogacia et evil de garde
le Tour de France c'est pas pour tout de
suite non alors je sais pas si on
réussira à faire mieux que Roland Garros
on a deux ans d'avance ou de retard
c'est selon un Noa 83 Ino 85 les années
80 béni parce qu'il y avait aussi
Platini et pros la France a changé la
France désormais et la meilleure nation
du monde dans les sports collectifs ça
marche beaucoup moins bien en individuel
c'est peut-être aussi une leçon pour
nous bien au-delà du Tour de France
c'est un pierre luxe Guillon ancien
patron du service politique de TF1
ancien patron du service politique de la
5 à laquelle j'appartenais autrefois qui
disait il ne faut compter que sur soi
mais on ne peut rien faire sans les
autres n'oublions jamais ça et c'est
vrai pour le vélo aussi il ne faut
compter que sur soi on ne peut rien
faire sans les autres c'est une leçon de
cycliste c'est une leçon de vie qui je
l'espère qui peut s'appliquer et devrait
s'appliquer à tout le monde surtout dans
la France de 2023 vous qui êtes sur les
routes du Tour évidemment dans votre
voiture tout au long de ce parcours
est-ce que la ferveur est la même
contient en français qui est en position
de gagner ou quand les Français sont un
peu plus loin la force du Tour c'est que
quelque soit les résultats des Français
c'est le tour et ça se voit aussi dans
les résultats d'audience France 2
triples sépare d'audience pendant le
Tour de France on était à 41% de parts
de marché sur les trois semaines l'an
dernier score magnifique
a relativiser avec les
87% au Danemark sur les trois premiers
jours les 78% sur les trois semaines
cercle le Tour de France au Danemark
c'est la finale de la coupe du monde de
foot avec l'équipe de France le Tour de
France le Tour de France en lien avec ce
que nous avons pu dire tout à l'heure
sur le rayonnement du Tour de France et
le fait qu'on aille régulièrement
l'étranger ce qu'encore une fois je
revendique donc de toute façon c'est la
fête le héros du Tour
c'est le tour d'abord
un mot sur le covid encore obligé d'en
parler il a perturbé le Giro il y a
quelques semaines plusieurs coureurs
contraint à l'abandon dont le leader
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet pour le
tour de cette année
alors aujourd'hui il y a plus de
contraintes officielle contrairement aux
années 2020-2021 2022 où les contraintes
venaient après discussion évidemment
avec le gouvernement évidemment avec
l'Union cycliste internationale avec les
équipes et avec nous organisateurs là
c'est reporté sur les équipes en
revanche on prendra des mesures de bon
sens c'est-à-dire que derrière le podium
quand les coureurs qui ont gagné ou qui
passent au contrôle antidopage doivent
rester derrière tout le monde devra
porter le masque et on demandera aussi à
nos amis journalistes je reste carte de
presse 56376 même si de fait je ne suis
plus journaliste de faire attention
évidemment par le port du masque avec
des perches quand il se rapprocheront
des coureurs l'année prochaine ce sera
les jeux de Paris le départ ce sera
Florence et l'arrivée ce sera pas sur
les champs ça c'est une petite
révolution l'arrivée à Nice ce sera la
toute première fois dans l'histoire du
Tour depuis 1903
Nice alors on ne remplace pas pareil
comme ça
Nice nous organisons nous avons des
contacts réguliers bien évidemment à
Christian estrosil maire de Nice on
avait évoqué ça avec lui dès décembre
2018 bien avant ensuite
et si ça n'était pas possible pour le
Tour de France d'arriver à Paris en 2024
et il avait dit évidemment bien sûr que
oui je serai là ça va nous permettre
aussi de rapprocher la montagne de Paris
le dernier contre-la-montre donc il y
aura un contre-la-montre de le dernier
jour le premier le dernier jour depuis
1989 les malus 8 secondes entre Greg
lemon l'Américain et Laurent finir donc
l'écart le plus serré de l'histoire du
Tour de France la montagne est là la mer
est là dernier chrono de Monaco à Nice
ça a de l'allure ça a de la gueule même
et ça résonne bien au-delà de la France
qui était aussi important parce que
Paris ça compte aussi Paris et ça veut
dire que le taux restera dans la moitié
sud l'année prochaine alors pas
simplement mais vous saurez tout le 27
octobre n'hésitez pas à vous
le soir à Nice où on fera une nouvelle
présentation du tour chez nos amis on
vient chaque année est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour la sécurité du Tour l'année
prochaine ça mobilise aussi des forces
de l'ordre évidemment le Tour de France
mais quand vous évoquiez quand vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les droits à
l'étranger c'était évident pour nous
qu'en 2024 de toute façon on ne pourrait
pas partir de France donc avoir un
certain nombre d'étapes en moins pour
soulager évidemment les forces de police
les forces de gendarmerie les forces de
sécurité mais deux en Italie oui la
première fois et ça tombe sur le
centenaire de la première victoire d'un
cours italien dans le Tour de France
Ottavio beauté qui a mort assassiné
alors choisissez la vérité ou la légende
il y a deux versions bien évidemment
comme toujours soit c'est parce qu'il
était antifasciste soit c'est simplement
parce que le voisin trouvait qu'il
faisait de trop fréquentes incursions
dans son jardin pour aller voir l'épouse
du Diwan
la Corse que je suis est obligé de vous
poser la question évidemment Christian
Prudhomme à quand le retour du tour en
Corse je sais pas mais en tout cas ce
qui est certain puisqu'on fait les 10
ans et j'ai été un interrogé cette
semaine par Corse-Matin par mon ami Noël
crushlin c'est un souvenir merveilleux
vous savez que j'évoquais la 5 tout à
l'heure
le patron qui m'a le plus marqué c'est
pire qu'en Johnny je crois qu'il est
Corse aussi et en fait c'était le rêve
de Pierre quand il était acteur en chef
du service des sports de la 5 et j'étais
l'un des membres de service de ce
service il nous racontait quoi il rêvait
de ça et qu'on ait pu faire ça
évidemment avec les élus avec d'abord en
chantilly qui a mis de roccasser et
ensuite celui qui a fait qui a dit oui
c'est c'est pas le Jacoby qu'on ait pu
faire ça trois étapes encore l'île de
Beauté montrer cette île extraordinaire
au monde entier c'était vraiment du pur
bonheur on peut espérer que ça revienne
alors en tout cas moi je n'hésite pas à
revenir régulièrement je me souviens de
m'être fait en guirlandais par certains
cours notamment Thomas vocaux en disant
c'est pas possible de faire ça c'est
trop beau et vous ne nous laissez même
pas le temps d'en profiter mais nous
reviendrons en vacances c'est ce qu'il a
fait
mais nous on espère que vous allez
revenir dans la course
nouvelle étape c'est très bon choix
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin on passe au
club des territoire